le 7-8 loisirs qui se poursuit à présent
avec une nouvelle a invité en plateau ou
virginie le vote
bonjour bonjour merci de nous rejoindre
ici donc à lille de loisirs pas très
loin du pnr bnr dont vous êtes la
chargée de communication le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
on est aux portes de ce pnr ici un parc
qui compte cinquante et une commune la
majorité sont dans les yvelines et puis
on a une partie une petite partie aussi
en essonne l'été en termes de tourisme
moment particulièrement important pour
le pmr
oui c'est un moment qui rassemble aussi
des gens venus un peu de tous horizons
des franciliens qui restent sur place et
qui ont envie un peu de s'oxygéner des
gens d'un peu plus loin de france et
d'autres pays
et c'est vrai qu'on a un territoire un
peu exceptionnelle qui marie des îlots
de nature extraordinaire du patrimoine
des sentiers aménagés des sites à
visiter
donc il ya une offre naturellement très
riche et il ya en plus un certain nombre
d'acteurs touristiques qui propose tout
au long de l'année et particulièrement
l'été des sorties aménager des visites
organisées des ateliers un peu insolite
voilà des choses qui permettent de
découvrir autrement le patrimoine et
donc du coup d'en profiter
voilà ce soleil ça le soleil on va
essayer de dresser un petit peu le
catalogue de ses différentes activités
nature patrimoine paysage terroir tous
ces aspects là sont mis en avant et puis
ça s'adresse et là je voudrais souligner
dès maintenant aussi aux plus jeunes il
ya des chantiers pour les jeunes pendant
l'été qui sont organisées au sein du pn
oui c'est une particularité aussi on
essaye de faire en sorte que des jeunes
est l'occasion de découvrir ce
patrimoine mais aussi en étant acteur et
donc il ya un certain nombre de
chantiers qui sont proposés ça peut être
des chantiers sur des sites naturels ou
pour lequel il ya des aménagements des
défrichements des mises en valeur de
sites anciens de vestiges sur lequel
voilà il ya des interventions pas trop
techniques qui sont à la portée de
personnes voilà non spécialistes qui
vont se réunir le temps d'un chantier
qui vont à la fois croisé d'autres
nationalités parce que tous les
chantiers qu'on a mené depuis plusieurs
années ça réunit des coréens d'aider des
philippins des
et des gens d'amérique du sud voilà
c'est vraiment un brassage déjà culturel
qui est passionnant c'est la découverte
d'un site et puis aussi de d'un rapport
au patrimoine comment l'entretien pour
qu'on entretient qu'est ce que c'est que
le travail de mémoire et en quoi c'est
important de garder ces vestiges et puis
après ils vivent ensemble et ensuite ils
découvrent ensemble directement aussi
puisqu'il ya une partie travaille le
matin une partie détente loisirs et
visite l'après midi donc c'est à la fois
voilà quelque chose d'utile quelque
chose de très agréable et c'est ouvert
évidemment à des internationaux puisque
c'est organisé avec l'association
rempart ile-de-france est évidemment
aussi ouvert à des locaux qui voudraient
profiter de l'occasion pour découvrir
donc c'est vraiment des rencontres
particulières il y en a au mois de
juillet qui sont déjà bouclées il y en a
au mois d'août qui sont encore ouverts
on peut aussi penser à nancy pour le
mois d'août
voilà donc il ya tous les renseignements
sur le site du parc et c'est vraiment
une expérience particulière pour joindre
l'utile à l'agréable
alors qui dit parc naturel dit aussi
forcément balade des balades pour tout
découvrir autour de différents thèmes et
les balades pour les petits curieux on
reste sur les enfants oui alors on a la
chance d'avoir des guides de parcs
extrêmement compétents qui connaissent
aussi bien la nature le patrimoine
l'histoire voilà tout ce qui est
intéressant et qui savent le transmettre
aux jeunes publics et donc ils proposent
ces rendez vous réguliers qui sont pour
des enfants de 6 à 12 ans où on va aussi
bien apprendre à calculer
là comment on calcule la hauteur d'un
arbre comme on apprend à se repérer en
forêt comme on décèle les traces de
présence animale dans un site comme on
fait une lecture de paysage par voilà
toutes ces choses là qui permettent de
faire une balade dans des paysages
évidemment très beau puisque c'est aussi
bien au milieu du marais demain cours
que de la forêt des hauts baignères
enfin voilà des sites un peu magique
quand on se dit qu'on est à 30 minutes
de paris c'est vrai que on débarque dans
ces endroits là et on se dit waow faire
voilà est donc en même temps on apprend
des choses on s'amuse
enfin voilà puis c'est vraiment des
guides passionnant donc on à solène qui
fait des visites avec une thématique
biodiversité un petit peu plus forte on
à aurélie ehrlich qui est guide
conférencière avec une forte connotation
médiévale et qui donc du coup propose
dans le cadre du château de la madeleine
des ateliers autour du moyen-âge aussi
bien la mode vestimentaire au moyen-âge
comment s'habille
mais pourquoi les codes vestimentaires
et puis les enfants apprennent aussi à
réaliser des accessoires fin voilà c'est
vraiment très pratique les blasons leur
signification comme on fabrique un
blason enfin voilà des choses qui
permettent de s'ouvrir un petit peu à
des choses moins connu et tout en ayant
voilà un cadre privilégié pour le faire
donc c'est vraiment des ateliers qui
marche très bien et qui sont vraiment
plébiscité par les enfants qui le font
les uns et les autres vous connaissez ce
pnr un petit peu vous avez l'habitude de
vous y rendre de découvrir des choses
le château de la madeleine louis on y on
le fréquente notamment pour des
reportages mais c'est très agréable
aussi d'aller s'y promener à la hauteur
en haut de ce village de saint rémy les
chevreuse et de chevreuse aussi injuste
juste à côté c'est vrai que c'est très
agréable
il ya pas mal de promenade à y faire on
parle peut-être de ces randonnées ses
ballades justement et on a quelques unes
ya même une application qui était lancée
oui alors l'application rendent au pnr
ile de france elle les communes en fait
aux quatre parcs et de l'île de france
puisqu'en fait la vallée de chevreuse et
l'un des ses quatre parcs naturels
régionaux
il ya le vexin il ya le gâtinais il ya
oise pays de france et ensemble ces
quatre parcs sont dit qu'ils avaient une
offre voilà de randonnée qui était
vraiment intéressante pour l'ensemble
des franciliens et que le faire ensemble
c'était plus rusé pour la mettre à
disposition beaucoup plus de circuits
dont il ya une centaine de balades et de
circuits référence et ça fait à peu près
1000 km de sentiers balisés qui sont
aussi bien que ses cibles à cheval à
vélo avait été appuyé par donc voilà on
peut choisir selon la durée le type de
paysage qu'on a envie de visiter le parc
qui est le plus proche de chez soi et
donc c'est vrai que ça permet voilà
d'avoir le circuit sur une appli avec en
plus des systèmes de téléchargement qui
font que le la cartographie et
télécharge à l'avancé donc du coup même
canton une capte pas ce qui peut arriver
on n'est pas perdu on a quand même le
système qui fonctionne et on peut quand
même continué sa balade même au plein
coeur de la forêt de rambouillet ou de
ou des étangs de hollande et nicolas
justement dans un instant vous parlerez
de ces différentes randonnées possibles
et notamment à la cheval on en parle
dans quelques minutes vous parliez des
vélos jeu
mme attendait un petit peu là dessus
avec l'aiguillage ouvert ses portes avec
des nouvelles boucles vélo aussi et des
locations de vélos possible tout à fait
c'est une maison d'éco mobilité qui est
idéalement situé en fête au pied du rer
b saint rémy les chevreuse c'est
l'ancienne maison du garde barrière qui
a été transformée et qui aujourd'hui est
à la fois un point touristique
d'information et un site qui permet de
faire à l'année du gardiennage de vélo
de la réparation de vélos de la location
est évidemment pour le côté villégiature
des locations de vélos classiques et des
vélos électriques ce qui avec le relief
de la veille de chevreuse n'est pas
inintéressant parce que quand on n'est
pas habitué
les panoramas c'est bien mais ça veut
dire qu'il ya des côtes on monte on
descend donc quand on n'a pas l'habitude
l'assistance électrique c'est vraiment
précieux et donc voilà il ya toutes ces
batteries de vélo classique vtt voilà
qui permettent de d'emprunter celui qui
vous correspond le mieux
et puis du coup de partir sur des
circuits qui ont été repérées on vous
donne une petite cartographie vous
pouvez voilà selon le temps dont vous
disposez faire une balade courtes
longues et vraiment profiter pleinement
pour découvrir les joies du vélo sans
forcément en avoir les peines quand on
n'a pas l'habitude aussi donc on vallée
de chevreuse un programme très riche et
puis pour conclure un petit peu l'été il
ya un festival qui est prévue à la fin
du mois d'août
oui à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse c'est la
commune qui l'organisé qui a décidé
voilà de prolonger un petit peu l'été
avec sur la dernière semaine d'août en
fait un rendez-vous des visites
notamment dans la réserve naturelle de
saint rémy les chevreuse qui est une des
rares réserves naturelles en milieu
urbain et puisqu'elle est au coeur des
habitations et qu'elle longe la rivière
de l'yvette donc y aura des visites
guidées il y aura des spectacles de
plein air il y aura des ateliers pour
enfants il y aura en partenariat avec la
maison raymond devos des concerts aussi
humoristique avec le barber shop quartet
qui est vraiment un super quartette
vocal voilà qui qui sera donc dans cet
équipement donc des rendez vous un peu
pour toutes catégories d'âge dans les
différents sites de la commune pour
vraiment voilà sur quatre jours avoir
l'opportunité de croiser le patrimoine
naturel qui est très riche à saint-rémy
avec tout le patrimoine historique aussi
k disposition il ya là même la maison
bojan ski qui est une une maison
d'architecte voilà d'un élève de
l'auteur buziet qui est situé à st rémy
qui sera également partenaire de
l'opération avec des ateliers des
spectacles s'y passe donc là aussi un
beau programme
une nouveauté en plus pour cette année
donc qui sera donc pour le mois d'août
et qu'on retrouvera sur le site du parc
voilà pour tous les renseignements
pratiques sur le site du parti pour tous
les renseignements pratiques très bien
pour la conclusion parfait si vous
maintenez les votes d'être venu nous
parler un petit peu des différentes
activités possibles en vallée de
chevreuse nous avons adressé nous
continuons à dresser un petit peu tout
ce que vous pourrez faire si vous restez
dans ce département des yvelines et vous
n'allez pas monter d'activité